alright guys so with star trek into
darkness on the horizon I'm very excited
for it this week and so is my buddy John
the flick pic we're gonna tell you guys
our thoughts on the first film by JJ
Abrams Star Trek I'll do my review first
and then you'll get his review second my
little ounce of Trekkie dumb I've never
really exposed to you guys before but I
actually was pretty into Star Trek when
I was a kid I loved the original series
and the next generation series I never
got into any of the others but I watched
him with my family when I was a kid I
said you probably gonna want to know
what my thoughts on all the other films
are I'll tell you them as quickly as I
possibly can
Star Trek the motion picture a kind of
boring movie that didn't really capture
the feel of the original Star Trek
series but still had some inspiring
moments and some good performances Star
Trek - the Wrath of Khan the best of the
original films Caan was excellent it had
a great suspenseful story and it brought
the original Star Trek roots in the feel
it back hmm
Star Trek 3 the search for Spock
directed by Leonard Nimoy a free
entertaining film but with not the
greatest fight scenes ever I kind of
hammy but fun Christopher Lloyd is the
villain but overall a pretty good Star
Trek movie Star Trek for the voyage home
also directed by Leonard Nimoy the one
with the whales as most people refer to
it one of the best and one of the
funniest Star Trek films look for a
great scene with Spock and Kirk on a bus
Star Trek 5 the final frontier William
Shatner said hey I would like to direct
a movie as well
Spock you did it I know I will no you
can't you actually suck
Star Trek 5 is the worst of the original
films by far I can't stand it - actually
it's terrible
Star Trek 6 the undiscovered country the
director of Star Trek 2 came back great
film great send-off for these characters
a lot of fun look for a great
performance by Christopher Plummer as
Chang the main villain moving in the
next generation we had Star Trek
generations a film that combined next
generation of Star Trek with all
generation in Star Trek a fun film at
times not great not the greatest villain
in Malcolm McDowell and a terrible
terrible ending that outraged fans
myself included that was completely and
stupidly unnecessary Star Trek first
contact directed by Jonathan Frakes or
Riker excellent film best of the next
generation films one of the best Star
Trek movies had the Borg as the main
villain it was great
Star Trek insurrection and kind of
boring an unnecessary film that felt
like a TV episode stretched out
stretched out if you know what I'm
talking about yeah facelifts and finally
Star Trek nemesis the best and most
member of
thing about this movie is that Tom Hardy
was featured as the villain clone of
Patrick Stewart not the greatest movie
it was okay but it wasn't a complete
disaster as James Lipton of inside the
Actor's Studio says he'll quickly we
have arrived at Star Trek I know if you
guys watch that show I watch it all the
time
Star Trek in 2009 was directed by JJ
Abrams and it surprised a lot of people
the only thing was really based off of
was Star Trek it was the characters from
Star Trek and that's all you know and a
lot of Trekkies were worried because it
looked like they were straying away from
various plot points of the original
shows and I was gonna mess up the
timeline the continuity and all kinds of
stuff I don't care about that because
this films successfully in my mind
rebooted and revamped Star Trek for
today's audiences and JJ Abrams Rhian
ejected energy into that that wasn't
there before that was sorely lacking I
really hope he does that with Star Wars
coming up soon this film is an origin
story and you get your first looks at
Kirk and Spock as kids and as they grow
older and how they're both sort of
wayward and they're looking for
something they're looking for something
to complete their lives something they
can devote their time to and they find
that in the enterprise and in each other
and one of the greatest things about the
original Star Trek show was that
relationship between Kirk Spock and
bones or McCoy and in this film that is
recaptured so beautifully with all of
these actors they did such a good job of
recreating the best parts of Star Trek
although the stories of Star Trek were
interesting and the special effects were
cool the best parts about those original
Star Trek shows were the characters
their interactions with each other and
the fact that you loved those guys and
even if the mission they were on wasn't
so interesting or fun you enjoyed
watching the characters because you
cared about them and that made the
mission all the more exciting even if it
wasn't that great and that's what JJ
Abrams realized with this movie because
he was able to successfully recreate
those characters for today's audiences
while still showing them love and it was
extremely exciting Eric Bana plays near
oh he's this time-traveling villain
who's taken people captive he's looking
for the Vulcan planet he wants to
destroy things and he's got an agenda if
you haven't seen the film I won't tell
you too much about it because it's fun
to go into this movie without knowing
that much just know that basically this
is a really fun sci-fi movie it's
actually really hilarious too because JJ
Abrams also has a pretty good way of
injecting humor into his movies without
making it feel forced there's this great
scene where Kirk's hands get all bloated
from some sort of injection that he gets
and that whole scene was just so out of
the blue I was cracking up I remember
Thomasson theaters so like I said JJ
Abrams realized that what made the
previous Star Trek films good the ones
that were good and the show were those
characters and he was able to
successfully recreate that for today and
all the actors Chris Pine Zachary Quinto
Karl Urban Zoe Saldana Anton Yelchin
Simon Pegg all these guys came together
and were able to make a new Star Trek
movie that successfully tributed that
original series in the original movies
but also made it fresh and new for a new
generation and critics and people all
praised the film alike despite the fact
that of course fans were like oh they're
called nudity and this and that it
doesn't matter to me kind of the same
thing forever my review for star trek
into darkness will probably be out this
late Wednesday early Thursday looking
forward to that but for now guys please
enjoy my buddy to flick pics review it
if you liked his review you can go check
out his channel
I left a link for that in the
description below thanks guys and enjoy
John's review hey there guys my name is
John this is the flick big channel and
here's my take on Star Trek
[Music]
anyway JJ the Lens Blur Abrams 2009 Star
Trek movie was like a shot of adrenaline
into the arm of Star Trek this movie
re-energized the franchise and brought
it to a new generation of fans that
might be a little bit younger and not
aware of it you know not everybody knows
who Leonard Nimoy is and I think that's
a crime against humanity and even if
you're not a huge Trekkie some people
call them trekkers either way if you're
not a huge fanatic of the series it
really introduces all these characters
to you for the first time but it does a
really good job but you know I'm telling
you who these people are there's
character development they get to the
point you're establishing these
characters and you can really get behind
them and it doesn't take the whole movie
to do so and that's one of the things I
really enjoyed about this movie is
because it stayed true to these beloved
characters you know it gave you that
origin story and it did so within like
the first 40 minutes of the movie and
most importantly what the movie does is
it goes into warp drive and you just get
into the story the movie starts Chris
Pine is Captain Kirk and Zachary Quinto
a spot and to me that duo of characters
is what makes Star Trek so great I mean
of course then you have the badass
enterprise but besides that these
characters are basically the heartbeat
of this movie and I think Chris Pines
performance in the movie is pretty damn
good you know after seeing him in a 2009
Star Trek movie I really can't imagine
anyone else you know playing the role I
think he was like a good new generation
William Shatner without the weird speech
patterns even though he does it one time
in the movie there's something about
this movie I really like I don't even
sound like William Shatner I sound like
Nicholas Cage and then you have Zachary
Quinto in the movie who plays Spock and
talked about blowing a performance away
this guy nails every scene that he's in
I really buy him a Spock he just has a
great screen presence about him and I
really bought him being a Vulcan in the
movie and the thing I've always liked
about Spock and the thing that they do
really well in this movie is they really
show how diverse his character is you
know he's half-vulcan half-human and
they blend that very well because at
times he's very emotional he has a lot
of aggression but other times he's very
level-headed and makes the right call
and I thought this movie did a great job
of showing that as far as the story of
plot goes at times it might get a little
bit overly complicated but you just have
to take it for what it is you don't see
skies up an enterprise they're in space
they're fighting Eric Bana his name is
narrow in the movie hello my name is
narrow that always always made me laugh
and the movies directed by JJ Abrams and
with JJ
usually get limbs flaring a little bit
of shaky camp but this movie air really
worked it fell like that new generation
of filmmaking really played out well in
this movie you know overall this movie's
just a lot of fun visually it's awesome
to look at as Leonard Nimoy coming back
to play Spock which is that right there
alone it's two thumbs up and the thing
about JJ Abrams Star Trek is this movie
could have failed so easily you know
there's so many things that they could
have done wrong that just you know
pretty much ruined the pre-established
franchise of Star Trek but they redid it
in such a way that it was creative it
was new it was interesting and for that
I'm have to give Star Trek the 2009
movie and so anyway guys I'm John this
is the flick pick channel that's my
quick take on Star Trek live long and
prosperous I'll see you next time
[Music]